so also these hospitals they don't want
to treat d transitioners because it
makes their statistics and data look bad
so you see all of these clinics trans
activists they'll claim there's a 1% D
transition rate why do you think that is
it's because they're not actually
treating them they just send them out
the door sorry we can't help you we
can't reconstruct your breast the
Medicaid or Medicare isn't going to pay
for that reconstruction so they don't
want those statistics and you know
that's what transactive always argued as
a 1% D transition rate but we know there
are so many there's a a Reddit group
online with 50,000 people in a
transition Forum I believe it's higher
than that now it's high this this is the
medical economy this is the dark side of
the medical economy that we all saw
during covid where hospitals wanted to
declare deaths related to covid because
it helped them helped their statistics
and their Federal grant money on the
other side so there's this whole dark
economy